各位同学大家好
接下来是关于Triton算的开发的一些相关内容
由我来跟大家一起分享交流一下
今天内容会从以下几个方面去讲
首先我们会介绍Triton的整体的一个相关的概念
以及在生存上的一个相关的适配情况
接下来呢我会做一些Triton算的开发指南的相关的介绍
包括Triton算的概数 安装与部署
Triton算的开发指南 Triton算的迁移
这部分主要是因为我们有一些内容
有一些算子其实是在GQ上做开发的
然后现在需要在生存上做一些适配
需要做一些迁移的一些相关的一些操作
在之后会介绍一下Triton算的调制指南
Triton算的性能分析方法以及相关的一些API
第一部分内容呢我们先分享一下Triton是什么
其实我们大家可以理解为一个Triton是一个GSL
就是一个领域的专用语言
它是跟那个CUDA是一个比较平行的存在
不过它上手的难度会稍微简单一点
会上手快一点
我们接下来看左边这几个模块
Triton的整体架构分三层
这层层是TritonC就是一个
和Python比较相像的一个编程接口
开发者可以使用Python语法来编写一些核函数
中间层是一些IR就是一些一系列的中间表达式
再往下就是它的一个编译模块
就是把Python代码能够对接一些
把Python代码转化成的中间表达式
对接底层的一些连续编译器
然后负责代码的运续生成和执行
编译器内部包括以下几个核心模块
第一个是machine independent passes
是与机器无关的一些优化步骤
就是一些通用优化
大家可以这么理解
就相当于是比如一些代码有点问题
写了一些死循环
或者一些有一些比较容易的代码这些
这部分就是帮你识别出来
然后做一些通用的优化
第二个就是与机器相关的优化步骤
这个就是主要是跟硬件相关的一些架构优化
比如说底层的一些指令级
或者一些缓存的优化
第三个osotuner就是一个
这是比较关键的一个组件
因为他会做一些自动的寻优
便利一些block size等一些参数
参数然后去找到一个最佳的一个配置
这个在我们写treats开发的时候也是比较关键的
后面我们也会把这个做一个具体讲解
然后和这个AutoTuner比较配合起来使用就是一个benchmark组件
他能够评估生成的机器码的性能表现
然后把结果反馈给AutoTuner
然后这两个形成一次
寻找最余组合
然后再评估
然后再平方往复去找到最佳组合的一个方法
从整体上来看呢
确实就是从上层的python转化成一系列的中间表达式
然后再到编译器去执行
再到核上去计算
那他有哪些优势呢
首先就是他比较简洁
他核心优势就是简洁
他代码是比较简单的
相当于是你也能看懂他表示什么样的操作
第二个就是他可移植性比较强
因为他这一系列的中间表达式是可以掩盖应链差异的
就能够跨应链部署
第三个就是开源生态
目前Titon的开源生态目前比较活跃
就是社区制度也比较完善
然后我们终于讲一下他的那个硬件的一个支持吧
就Titon不仅仅支持GPU就比如英伟达和AMD的GPU
然后我们生存上也是做了一些适配
我们核心就是构建一个TitonSense一个适配层
然后将那个我们的SNPUI直接到这个TitonIR
就是实现有从派生编程到NPU执行的全链路的一个能力
就整体的包括算是开发
编译优化和部署推理
接下来我们去看一下这个Titon CUDA和SNC的一个差异
Cuda是B原的
它支持英伟达的一些相关的一些硬件
然后开发难度会比较高
不过它性能会比较好
然后SNC是一个最比较扑大的一个编程的一个算论开发
然后目前是部分开源的
然后后面会逐渐走向开源
它的入门难度和那个性能也基本上是Kuda是对应的
然后Titon就是入门就比较简单
它是开源的
然后会有很多的相关的一些社区的一些文档或什么教程
然后它的入门难度非常低
因为是Python的主要是主语言
开发周期会比较短
基本上就是如果我们内部就是做一些培训的话
也是对于一些零技术的同时
就相当于内部培训一天之内也能够写出一些
可以运行的Demo什么的
所以基本上只要环境部署好了
就是做启程测的开发是比较快的
在编程范式方面
Kuda它的编程范式是一些细粒度的一些线纯底的并性
如果大家看过GPU的架构的话
相当于是你可以看到它是一个SM
然后再往下就是分成了Grade
然后Block里面还有一个Thread
就是相当于是整体的是一个四个层次的一个架构
一个每个线程处理一个小块
所以它是一个线程级的定型
然后Triton采用的是一个粗粒度的会计并性
就是一个大块
然后也就是我们说的那个Telos
或者说Blocks
就是编程的一个抽象的层次会比较高一点
就不需要手动管理一些线程同步
或者是一些底层的一些其他的一些细节
嗯这个就是我们那个TratenSense
就是对接到呃我们的B生编译器的Ason的NPIR
然后然后去支持一个Traten的一个适配情况
右边呢就是一些就是相当于Traten在底层
适配不同硬件也是通过一些IR表达式来完成的
就是通过IR表达式
然后呃将那些呃Python的语言
呃转换成那个硬件的二线程
然后在各一边上去指定
接下来就是我们讲一下就是如何在车口上去使用
去使用Traten
也就是如何去安装
然后去使用去调试去性能分析这些
首先呢我们讲一下概述啊
这个就是我们在其实我们在内心的影片上
可以收到接收TratenSense
就收到我们的官方文档
大概的目录结构呢就分成左边这几块
包括安装指南
去寸的速度开发
算子轻移
嗯
调试调诱以及一些相关的API接口
首先呢就是
安装和部署这一部分
因为TratenSense的整体是基于看去做的嘛
所以这一部分依赖看的安装和部署
在我们社群官网上
就是社群社区上可以找到我们的看的一个下载的一个地址
嗯
就是我们在这个页面下就是选择我们目标的一个看版本
然后以及我们的硬件产品
以及在选择我们的CPU架构
呃以及我们偏好的操作系统
然后
呃可以去
根据我们不同的安装方式去有一个安装的一个指导
左下角就是就是
视力的一个安装的一个
呃一些命令相关的一些部署的情况
第二个就是那个TratenSense的安装和部署
嗯
就是讲两种方式
第一种就是通过Pype安装
我们有一些日购件的包
包括
嗯
这个Traten的就是可以直接安装就行了
就通过Pype install
可以安装
嗯
就是需要注意的是就是有一些
有一些比如我们的环境上其实已经有了Traten
然后如果是我们安装3.2.0以下版本的TratenSense的话
就是
建议是把原来的那个原生的那个Traten给卸载掉
因为这可能存在一些冲突
在我们3.2.1以上版本的话
我们
呃
安装的话会覆盖安装水层
这个就会比较复杂一点
下面就是我们这几个核心的一些安装步骤
需要安装就是
其他一些依赖项
就是会比较复杂嘛
如果大家就是想快速上手的话
还建议通过Pype install
进行安装
就除了这两个UI呢
就是我们就是对于Python版本
和一些相关依赖帮我们
设计上也有相关的文档
去说明
可以到设计官网上去查一下
安装部署完之后
就是我们就来
嗯
一起看一下这个程度算计的一个色子开发一个相关的指南
就是对于我们
矿图算手的话
我们就是可以掌握就两个点
就是一个就是多核任务并行和单核数据搬运
就是我们生存是达分型加工嘛
然后以我们达分型加工为例
嗯
就是我们计算核心就是AI core
它里面分为cube计算单元和那个vector计算单元
在我们那个架构里vector和cube计算单元的数量是1:2的
就是一个cube对用两个vector
所以就是一个设计到一些多核并行相关的
理论上就是我们的一些产品
比如910b910c
应该是二次cube
所以并行运算的核是20个
遇到每一个核里的
嗯
大家可以看过相关的一些我们那个架构图
一般都是从HBM去搬运数据
然后搬到对应的HHR cache里面
然后再从不同流水去做cube的计算
形成一种流水并行的情况
所以我们整体来说的话就是
去讲这个多核这种例行和大核数据端运这两个内容
再来看呢就是
做确认算的开发的话
就是第一个就是首先要看
要获取一个vector和cube的核数
因为这个核数是比较关键的
是那个进行计算的一个基础
比如看这边它首先会获取device的内容
通过这个number vector core
去获取相应的那个核数
核数也是相应的一个获取方式
例外来说那个核数应该是20个
这边是一个attention forward的一个
代码的一个一部分的实现
可以讲一下就是嗯
这个hats这个tracing.git
就是我们的一个装饰器
就用来注明这个这段那个代码
是要在npu上去执行的
然后这边就是那个number
cord
就是我们上一步在这边获取的一些核数
在吹吹里面对并计算的数量是有要求的
就是对于吹吹来说的话
它的下发的那个县程并发
就是不超过六五三五
但是在我们那个
就生存这边吹吹的这边
嗯我们其实要求
因为我们达平架构有20个克嘛
所以我们启动20个以上的核心的话
就会
有核的一些重新启动的一些开销
就是比较大
所以我们建议的就是
以物理核数为绑定
就比如我们这边
I cost 20个核
所以在这边去指定
去做并行的话
也是指定20个
性能会比较好一点
然后对于就是vex算子开发的话
它分核数应该就是vex的一个核数量
然后对于cv融合算子来说的话
就是分核数就是
cube核数量
就是我们
factor的一半
就是我们所说的20个
接下来就是讲一下这个单核数据搬运
单核数据搬运呢
就是下面有一些
嗯
其实一些注意事项
首先就是我们要设置合适的一个循环的一个block size
因为block size的主要是影响两个点啊
就一个就是block size过大的话
它可能会导致那个
嗯
相当于是我们ub上的一个内存溢出
因为它这个block size是比较大的话
如果比较小的话
相当于是我们
因为我们计算的话是通过
呃
总那个
计算量大小除以这个block size的话
这样的话计算的那些数量如果比较大的话
会呃
高于我们刚才说那个tretton的一个
最大并化上限
然后就会导致一些
呃
也会导致一些异常
然后
就是其实我们tretton有一个autochel自动调优的一些能力
就是根据我们可以指定几组block size
然后我们会用这些block size去去做许优
去做计算吧
然后把呃
每一组去跑一个数据
然后得到一个性能最优的数据
然后最后反汇回来
就这个除了block size
还可以试试一些其他的一些参数
比如我们矩阵计算的时候
需要对行和列做切分
然后以及一些切分块
这些都可以
参数都可以用
Auth2功能去做一些自动调优
然后接下来呢
就是还有一个注意点
就是要保证就是我们参数的尾轴大小
呃
尾轴大小数据是对齐的
因为嗯
相当是如果我们不对齐的话
我们会有一个
就是在我们计算的时候肯定是要补齐的
就是会有一些补齐的
会有一些性能一些开销
如果我们对齐的话
就相当是可以把这性能做的更好一点
对于vector的话
咱的那个对齐是32季节
32笔
然后对于随为融合算子的话
那尾轴数据
尾轴大小的话
就是512笔
接下来一个需要注意点就是
我们在计算的时候
尽量是把一些呃
大块数据先搬运到UB上
然后再从UB上去取目标值
因为如果我们每次就是搬运就是
那block会比较小的话
就是小块的数据的话
就会有一个频繁从
那个
UB到
我们的
那个
反程
就是
就是来回的一个
数据搬运的一个性能开销
接下来就是存算
优化的一个注意事项
就是
呃
一般来说
就是如果对于
嗯
存算并行的话
就是我们相当于是需要
从全局存上搬数据到片上内存
然后完成计算之后
再搬下一批数据
这种
相当于是在搬运过程中
就是我们的那些计算单元
会
就是在
属于是空闲状态
就是在等待
就是我们搬运的数据
就这样的话
效率会比较低
如果是存算并行的话
就现在是我们
在搬运第一批数据的同时
已经开始做一些计算了
然后后面再继续搬运第二批数据
这样的话
就会做一些
就形成那种搬运和计算
一个重叠的流水线
就会做一些通信
就是存算的一个掩盖
能够提升整体的存土率
和一些性能
然后接下来就是讲一下
那个确准算的迁移
嗯
确准算的迁移的话呢
就是它的
有几组
那个
有一个运转
就是
首先呢
显示的
就是我们需要把
就是
比如看一些代码
看一下右边这个示例
就是需要把一些
把一些那个
哈权PU进行导入
然后把一些
就什么显示的一些
代码里面提到
古兰或
GPU的相关代码
进行注释或替换
然后就是
嗯
其他一方面呢
就是比如
对于grade来说的话
就是GPU那边
对它是
grade是按逻辑来分的
所以它grade定义的
会比较自由一点
然后在圣盒这边
我们尽量是
需要是把
我们grade
跟物理核组去做一些绑定
就是我们物理上
有多少核
然后
去
制定的那个grade
也是制定多少
这样的话
就是我们的性能
会比较好
然后就是我们的
嗯
仿存对齐
以及一些
GPU的一个
专属的一个API
需要去
去除掉
就是那个
仿存对齐
就是我们刚才讲的那个
Wix算子的话
要求32字节
就是
CV融合算子需要51字节
对齐
接下来我们
介绍一下
GPU顺算子迁移的
一些常见的问题
第一个
这两个问题
其实刚才我们都讲的
主要就是因为那个
block size
设置了一个
大小破坏式的情况
嗯
首先是那个
超限问题
就是说我们的
刚才讲那个block size
设置过小的话
然后它的那个
计算量除以它的block size
得到了一个线程并发数
会
大于6535
会超限
这样的话就是我们
可以
解释就是把我们block size
稍微调大一点
然后保证就是这个不超过限制
第二就是UB公斤一出
相当于是我们刚才说的
这样子就是block size
过大
然后
导致
呃
我们那个
变成内存的UB公斤
就会
超出
就是它的一个容量上限
其实这种除了那个block size
就是
过大的话
还有一种
就是我们七分不太合理
相当于我们有很多
就是没有对齐的房存
然后导致我们在对房存进行
进行
呃
补齐的话
会有一些额外的一些空间
或是存取一些
开销
会导致我们的空间益处
在就是
我们做的开发过程中
除了就是我们刚才的一些开发的一些
一些
一些细节就是
还有一些就是我们需要知道如何去debug
就是比如
看到一些报错
你们应该去如何去定位
这是我们需要转换的一点
首先呢
就是我们看一下就是
简单看一下那个
推送的一个编程流程
嗯
应该就是
基本上就是通过
将我们的内python语言
然后转成一些中间
中间未来式
以及经过一些适配层
然后
最后转就是
到我们硬件的二进制
然后去执行和
呃
运算
嗯
大家可以看一下
就是我们这个
这个图
就相当于是我
就是我们
相当于是我们
相当于我们
对于开发的来说的话
就是我们主要关注的
就是一个
上纸的开发
的实现代码
就相当于是一个python语言的
可以看到这个
x1
通过这种
tl.load的方式
这个就是确认那个
刚才数据的一个方法
通过这种方式
就是完成了一个数据加载了
然后也通过
tl.store
进行了一个数据的一个存储
然后我们在中间这个
这个就是相当于是一系列中间
表来式
转换的表来式
可以看到
在
嗯
8%这一行
就是
就是相当于对应我们刚才那个
tl.load的
这款数据
然后
11%这一行就对应我们刚才的
那个
tl.load的那个
store那个数据
相当于我们这些都是
一对应的
就是我们的
就能看到就是我们
从我们代码到
GVL
到后下层的那个
适配层都是能一对应的
好
接下来我们讲一下就是
针对这个编译流程
我们有哪些调试方法
首先就是一个打印的一个调试方法
就是我们有一个静态打印和运行式打印
这个的话需要我们在打印的之前需要我们设置一些环境变量
就比如
Treated device print
把这个
变量设置为一
静态打印
是相对于
呃
运行式打印的话就相对于是它的
不会有呃
性能开销就是它不会
对性能产生影响
因为它打印的主要是一些场量和场量给达试
然后如果是运行式打印的话
因为打印长量或一些变样的话
就会对性能有一些开销
除了打印调试方法之外
就是我们
嗯
就是那种爆错的一条方法
就还有一个Python代码的一个调试
以及C++代码的调试
就通过PGB设置断点
然后一些其他我们常见的一些单部执行啊
或者一些其他的一些调试方法
能够帮我们在定位Python代码的时候
能够有一个很好的一个效果
然后C++的话就是在原版里面插入一些调试语句
然后添加那个VLM调试一个输出流
然后打印看一下有哪些具体的一些爆错信息
接下来呢我们介绍一下C++的一个性能分析方法
这边就是我们主要讲两种方法
第一种就是我们那个主要采集的一个性能分析方法
就是我们主要采集的一个性能分析方法
主要采集的一个性能分析方法